Mark Wahlberg joining us actor of course
but more importantly Patriots fan how
you feeling today hey buddy how are you
great great were you nervous at all on
Sunday absolutely I mean I was nervous
before the game started I you know oh my
god it was crazy and you know I mean how
many times can they go to the west like
that well you know what is the scene
like are you watching with the kids no
my son's got a sleepover so they didn't
come home until like midway through the
first half so it was just my wife and
then I had some friends because I had
some of the franchisees from all burgers
over we're having a meeting with my
brother Paul and so they were there one
guy in Florida you know he's kind of act
like he's not rooting for the Jags but
you can tell that he is and so I'm going
from room to room then the cable went
out my wife's now was an obsessed fan so
she doesn't really know exactly what's
happening but she still gets crazy so
I'm like trying to stay away from her
and I'm just kind of do whatever I got
to do to kind of walk around and get in
the right headspace you're like you're a
mess yeah I put my lucky watch did you
pray did you have the kids pray for Tom
Brady's hand no okay
you didn't get that desperate no we were
already praying for Brian Hoyer to come
you got the call are you going to
Minneapolis I'm going to try but I'm I'm
shooting a movie with Pete Berg and
Peter got no no no team in the hunt so
he doesn't he's not interested in that
we have right now we have a Sunday
schedule we're shooting these weird
weekend so I'm going to do everything
that I can to get him to let me out
because obviously my wife and my kids
want to go as well but you know look I
also I've been preparing for the Eagles
I get back to the Super Bowl
Oh Paulie my hos and bear is playing
Vespa Paulie in the movie you know
although Brandon Graham has been texting
me pockets Mac already and then I try to
FaceTime yesterday he didn't take my
call but why
why are you scheduling a movie this time
of the year you know this is this is the
Super Bowl this is patriot time and
you're shooting a movie well I think
they'd get here mark is that what you're
saying no no that's not the case I gotta
work do that you know as much as I love
the Patriots they don't pay the bills so
I gotta I gotta work while I can you
know these kinds of jobs are not
promised forever so but Pete and I we
started shooting this movie in November
and then we had to break for the holiday
for Christmas for new year so it's not a
long shoot but it's certainly been
dragged out so we have another break
that we're moving to another location so
it's just been it's just been kind of
all over the place given what happened
last year at the Super Bowl is there a
different strategy if you do get to go
to the game do you have a game day
strategy different than last year's I
think honestly I don't think the game is
going to be that close I think if you
look at how I've been kind of feeling
out what's been going on with with
Pittsburgh versus the Jag with Atlanta
and the Eagles and then with the
comeback against the Saints from
Minnesota you know I really felt like
the Eagles were gonna blow them out
Minnesota kind of shot their load Eagles
now have had their celebratory time and
I think they're kind of happy to be
there I don't think I don't think folks
could do it again like that I think we
kind of finally have the first easy
victory win by a couple touchdowns so
bad for viewership but good for Patriots
as we age you know rapidly over
stressful situations I'm gonna be
hosting the Super Bowl so if if you're
around you want to stop by you know be
more than happy to get your expertise
it's one of our analyst I would love to
but I tell you I could not be happier
for Philly for blunt for Brandon Graham
I mean that you know it's especially
because being able to work in
Philadelphia being welcomed into
Philadelphia as an honorary Philadelphia
they don't give love easy so you know it
was an honor for me to put on the Eagles
uniform to play vespa poly you know to
work with Greg Kinnear playing dick for
meal
so I couldn't be happier you know if for
some miracle where the Eagles were to
win I would actually be able to smile
for the city of Philadelphia and all the
wonderful people that I know there did
you ever consider trying to buy a sports
team you know when I watch that crap
special when he bought the Patriots 175
million another war 3.7 I why in 94 I
was scrapping pending together you know
if there were this day and age I
couldn't actually got in there the
Patriots at a discount which team would
you buy mmm
well any any first of all anything New
England team first but if I said you can
have your pick
Bruins Red Sox Patriots Celtics oh it
has to be the pager is really we
definitely have to it still feels like
it's a red sock town now you know it
depends it depends and you know what the
Red Sox or you know our beloved
throughout New England but the but being
called the New England Patriots you know
so many other people Connecticut Vermont
New Hampshire Maine can also claim them
as their own
even Connecticut which is so close to
New York you have kind of people that
are either New York or or New England
but you know the Patriots have done so
much for the city and you know they've
been so down I mean these dominated in a
way where I think the only other team
you could say they kind of had that run
maybe the Celtics in the Russell error
tell Berg we set a low safe travels and
perhaps we'll see in Minneapolis thank
you buddy all right take care
thank you Mark that's Mark Wahlberg for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you